الصحه العالميه تحذر من خطر بيولوجي كبير
في السودان
العفو الدوليه تطالب لبنان بايقاف ترحيل
السوريين قصرا
واندونيسيون يهربون للمرتفعات خوفا من
حدوث تسونامي
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
ونبدا من السودان حيث اعلنت منظمه الصحه
العالميه ارتفاع عدد القتلى الى 459 شخصا
وعدد الجرحى الى اكثر من 4000 نتيجه
المعارك الدائره في البلاد منذ الخامس عشر
من ابريل الجاري ممثل المنظمه في السودان
نعمه سيد عابد حذر في تصريحات من خطر
بيولوجي يهدد الخرطوم بعدما سيطر احد
الطرفين طرفي الصراع على معمل يحتوي على
مسببات الحصبه والكوليرا وغيرها من المواد
الخطيره كما ذكرت المنظمه ان هناك مخاطر
حقيقيه تجاه انتشار الاوبئه في البلاد
خاصه الكوليرا
وقبل الحدث بنحو عام ونصف وعبر مقطع فيديو
اعلن رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن رسميا ترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله منهيا كل
الشكوك بشان اعاده ترشحه الرئيس الامريكي
قال ان سباق العام المقبل هو معركه بوجه
التطرف الجمهوري على حد وصفه فيما اعتبر
الحزب الجمهوري ان بايدن منفصل عن الواقع
بعد اعلان قراره هذا خوضه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه محذرا من ان فوزه سيؤدي الى
مواصله التضخم بارتفاعه الصاروخي وارتفاع
معدلات الجريمه في الولايات المتحده
في لبنان تجددت عمليات ترحيل اللاجئين
السوريين قصرا الى بلادهم مره اخرى فيما
طالبت منظمه العفو الدوليه السلطات
اللبنانيه لوقف عمليات الترحيل المنظمه
اوضحت انها تخشى ان يتعرض اللاجئون الى
التعذيب او الاضطهاد من قبل النظام السوري
عند عودتهم الى بلادهم مؤكده انه يجب
حمايه اللاجئين الذين يعيشون في لبنان من
المداهمات التعسفيه والترحيل غير القانوني
الى مكان تتعرض فيه حياته هؤلاء للخطر
فيما تاتي دعوه المنظمه بعدما رحلت
السلطات اللبنانيه حوالي 50 سوريا الى
بلادهم خلال الشهر الجاري
جدل واسع تشهده بريطانيا حاليا بسبب قانون
جديد قد يؤدي الى حظر تطبيق واتساب ومعه
عدد من التطبيقات المماثله حيث يكاد لا
يخلو هاتف في بريطانيا من هذا التطبيق
الذي اصبح اداه التواصل الاولى في البلاد
وبحسب تقرير النشاط الصحيفه الديليلمين
فانه في حال اصرت الحكومه البريطانيه على
المضي قدما في تطبيق قانون السلامه الذي
يضعف التشفير الكامل للمراسلات مراسلات
واتساب بالتحديد فانه سيؤدي لحظر التطبيق
الشهير الذي
سيرفض الالتزام بالقانون اذا تم اقراره
ختامه هذه النشره من اندونيسيا التي ضربها
زلزال بقوه 7.1 درجه قباله سواحد سماطره
بحسب ما افادت به الوكاله الجيولوجيه
الامريكيه ما ارغم السكان الى اللجوء الى
المرتفعات قبل ان يرفع الانذار باحتمال
حصول تسونامي وقبل وقوع الزلزال بساعات
قليله اطلق الباحث الهولنديه المثير للجدل
فرانك هوجر بيتس تحذيرا من قرب حدوث زلزال
قوي وحدد منطقه السناتره بانها ستكون عرضه
للزلزال نظرا للتقلبات الجويه مرفقا صورا
للكره الارضيه بعلامه محدده لحدوث
التقلبات الجويه بمناطق عده من العالم